quand on voit là la gestion de cette
crise et une gestion d'urgence le
constat est plutôt catastrophique pour
un pays comme la france
alors vous savez là je connais dans une
guerre dos collé au trot il y était
question qu'on peut se poser
il ya des questions encore campus
opposera plus tard donc le nombre de
stocks de masques
oui je sais il a diminué normalement
durant les dernières années
il faudra faire des enquêtes et savoir
garder aujourd'hui on n'est pas là
aujourd'hui il faut juste de savoir si
demain on n'allait pas dans les hôpitaux
en accusation le travail et il faut
savoir comment on va des pistes et
l'ensemble de la population à la fin de
confinement est ce que on va savoir si
les gens sont porteurs encore du virus
ici plants porteurs du virus tout faire
évidemment pour qu'il soit toujours en
quarantaine et connais pas un phénomène
de redon et puis savoir si les gens sont
ils unissent oui mais pour cela philippe
douste-blazy la fin il va falloir tester
les personnes à la fin du confinement
le ministre de la santé table sur 20
mille dépistages par jour alors que
l'allemagne en a promis 200 milles au
quotidien au mois d'avril comment est ce
qu'on va pouvoir procéder alors je crois
quelque chose différent montain dans les
tests dans vous parle et qui sont des
tests
pqr que d'amplification génique ça c'est
les chiffres actuels et qu'il souhaite
qu'on arrive à demi-mot 20002 âge par
jour actuellement
la question que je pose est est tout à
fait différente il à la fin les
confinements à l'aja le gouvernement est
prêt à faire beaucoup
que valent mille par jour il faudra
vraiment tester la population française
pour mettre à l'écart ceux qui sont
affectés parce que des pays en effet ont
une stratégie différente comme la corée
du sud comme le japon et même vous
l'avez dit l'allemagne puis viser l
dépister très largement la population et
ensuite un vêtement 40 et comment les
gens contaminés
c'est comme ça qu'ils ont des taux plus
bas et surtout et une mortalité plus bas
mais ça c'est fait c'est fait on n'en
parle plus d'emplois plus tard mais pour
l'instant ce n'est pas le sujet le sujet
c'est comment on se prépare maintenant
au dépistage massif des français à la
sortie du contenu